the helpful entertaining consistently
supportive and occasionally extremely
irritating but there's no denying the
importance of a really good sidekick
sorry for today's episode of the gist
I've decided to go over five of my
all-time favorites my first choice is
kind of a contentious one since while
the Little Blue Fairy certainly has her
fans she had pissed off a lot of the
gaming community by screaming hey and
then subsequently demanding that to
listen but he is why I reckon you should
give Nobby a chance okay so you can't
get from one end of hyrule field to the
other without a shrill intrusion but the
second you crack into a combat scenario
or need to chuck your boomerang at a
specific point the Navi assisted Zed
targeting system is your very best
friend
besides that helpful addition she's more
than happy to drop the one weakness of
the gigantic Queen Girma beastie
residing in the Deku Tree and that of
any other less than friendly beastie hue
encounter Navi does more than just throw
you med packs or say she's got a bad
feeling about something she's a guide
your main combat asset and stops you
being that weird boy without a fairy
that everybody else in the forest makes
fun of the Mass Effect series could
pretty much fill out its own top 5
sidekicks sure between waters and
singing and Garrison's incessant
calibrations but my favourite also
happens to be one of the only proper
action figures that I own
Holly Sora a serious contender for
companion most worthy of romancing after
Liara tally is the toughest
strong-minded Quarian mech that you'll
ever come into contact with you know
because that's a long list between
heartbreaking tribulations with her own
people - watching her get drunk through
her emergency induction ports not only
is her backstory solid but she's
extremely handy with a shotgun
having a drink with my boyfriend my
human boyfriend my mother would have
hated you if you've got a soft spot for
Tali like I do I would definitely
recommend not watching the scene where
you can accidentally cause her death you
will have a bad time if the word
meatbags live somewhere within your
vocabulary then chances are you decided
to drop by Tatooine during your Knights
of the Old Republic playthrough to pick
up assassin droid HK 47 HK is not the
most complimentary of droids and have a
tendency to be generally snide but he is
fiercely loyal to his masters that is
until they mostly meet their untimely
demise he was programmed to see all
organics as meatbags and doesn't have a
whole lot of regard for human life
regardless of this hk's tendency to
begin remarks with speech conditionals
that describe the kind of statement he's
about to make and his proud charismatic
nature make him a sidekick whose
dialogue you rarely want to skip through
here I am surrounded by all these meat
bags and all I desire is true perfection
the second Knights of the Old Republic
game asked the player to reassemble HK
using several different components and
trust me it's well worth the effort
staying off the humanoid track next up
we have a bird who spent most of his
life locked in a pirate chest to then
head off with an art-student to save the
twin worlds from peril yeah it's
complicated the longest journey tells
the story of a Ryan who finds herself as
so many young people do faced with the
duty of saving the world and a whole
other parallel version there she
wouldn't have got very far without crow
sailing through the sky outside of
floating warlock castle or pecking bird
species off of an ancient dragon statue
her fine feathered friend is charismatic
sarcastic and kind of a womanizer I
ain't stopping until I can spot those
cute chicks from miles and miles away
like so many of these examples crows one
of those sidekicks that goes beyond just
being a support character and becomes of
tropical pain
as illustrated by my Twitter and
Facebook backgrounds one of my favorite
old-time sidekicks is the strong loving
silent types the weighted companion cube
here's the thing about the weighted
companion cube it dies like a lot and
you spend most of the game giving it
terrible long standing abandonment
issues as a result of leaving it behind
every time you progress to a new chamber
whether it actually gives a crap about
you or it's just the misleading heart
painters on its faces it's hard to say
but where there's a cube switch to be
filled this sidekick is at the ready
nonetheless I think I have to side with
GLaDOS on the fact that the little cube
cannot speak and if it does its advice
should be disregarded so those are some
of my favorites but be sure to let me
know in the comments down below or on my
Twitter where I'm at Jeff McDonald who
your favorite sidekicks might be I'll be
back next week with another wrap-up of a
gaming feature but until then try to go
easy on Navi
you